land und brecht
[Musik]
ich will morgen sicherheit guten morgen
markus wo erreiche ich dich in der hit
bewerten können du bist bei der arbeit
ja ja im augenblick viel zu schreiben
weil sie ich habe sehr interessant
kennst du andrea wolf ja die hat dieses
großartige buch überholen als gast in
einer sendung auch wirklich ja das ist
ja ein weltbestseller gewesen richtig
und die hat mir mal erzählt wie sie wie
sie das so trennt diese beiden welten
also wenn sie bücher schreibt dann
versinkt sie völlig in ihrer eigenen
welt und uns hat nicht
den satz und dann bin ich so mit meinen
eigenen leuten
ja damit die figur lassen nicht an die
genau die historischen und finja wie
hast du das auch jaja ich versinke da
auch sehr sehr tief drin und das ist
auch immer schwierig heraus zu kommen
also das ist so dieses umschalten und
wieder in die realität anzupassen
ja ja genau das kommando offen minute
und so das feld extrem schwer und und
was was immer auf der strecke bleibt
sind all die anderen sachen die man am
schreibtisch auch erledigen müsste und
der schriftsteller gisbert haefs der
sehr gute historische romane geschrieben
hat er hat erzählt er habe zwei
schreibtische okay ein schreibtisch an
dem man seine bücher schreibt und den
anderen schreibtisch oder den restlichen
kreml erledigt und das finde ich
großartig aber du wirst es mir nicht
glauben ich habe es bislang nicht zu
zwei schreibtischen gebracht du hast ja
kein platz in der krieg hatte das
internet in der kemenate arbeite ich
sowieso nicht da ist also das würde gar
kein schreibtisch reinpassen in der
kemenate machst du was ist also liest du
dann drei ist meine bibliothek drin also
ein teil muss man sagen ist ja nun
vielfach verteilt aber die ist also ran
vollgestopft und gestapelt und büchern
und wie gesagt auch in dicken brocken
auf dem boden und da ist also ein
erbärmliches gästebett doch drin mit dem
ob ich jetzt gerade auf so ner yoga
matte
und und diese da müssen muss unterarme
besucher
das in kombination mit seiner frisur
ergibt für mich plötzlich alles sehen
wie yoga matte ja dann diese ich habe
noch nie eine sanierte werfen mir in
meinem leben yoga gemacht also wirklich
nicht mehr aber ich bin froh dass es die
roma gibt weil so ich hab ja judo
gemacht bin ja eigentlich gewohnt so auf
den boden zu sitzen
wir haben ja früher manchmal so
besonders hart zu sein unsere judo
rolling stone auf den boden gemacht ohne
matten und so aber so mit 750 freut man
sich über die yoga matte ja ich finde ja
kampfsport als jude und so das ist echt
hart noch sehr verletzungsanfällig auch
als erwachsener ganz extrem hast du dir
mal was gerissenen kreuzband oder so in
der nähe kreuzband nicht aber ich habe
mir in der jugend als ich das so
leistungsmäßig noch verfolgt habe und so
viel an turnieren teilgenommen habe
alles mögliche also hatte gebrochen
fußgelenk gebrochen das schmerzhafteste
was ich hatte war eine schulterprellung
also prellungen sind ja viel
schmerzhafter als total daher absolut
und eine schulterprellung da musste man
so über den ganzen oberkörper muss man
so ein verband tragen und die kleinste
bewegung hat alle genre ja da hat er
mich also mein kampf partner das ist für
dich idiotische gegen eine wand geworfen
dann hörten keine als großes julio
studio ja und dies tat einfach nicht
immer als wir der wand nahe kam und
spindeln völlig gegen die wand
geschmettert worden auch margot umgang
und das heißt du wärst heute wenn die
jemand kommt du wirst in der lage den um
zu mieten soweit die idee hannah also es
ist gott sang lange nicht mehr passiert
lange nicht mehr das heißt es ist schon
mal passiert na ja es ist natürlich also
ich war jemand der sich so früher in der
kindheit und so weiter habe ich mich
immer gerne geprügelt deutlich ja wenn's
doch doch was und friedfertiges kind das
geistige konflikte ausgetragen aber das
war ich hier auch so spaß kempchen das
war weil man ja auch judo konnte und so
machte das ja auch spaß ich mit leuten
anzulegen die schlecht ein bisschen
größer waren aber wo man mithilfe von
julio eben dann doch zu seinem kam so
du willst ja mal ausdrücken aber was man
heute noch wirklich könnte oder nicht
könnte in einer ernsten situation ich
glaube da kann ich gar nicht vorurteile
weißt du gar nicht nur immer lese also
ich bin einfach froh nicht in der
situation zu sein ja in der tat richtig
weh hast du du hast ja so ne und ich
glaube unsere söhne sind ungefähr gleich
alt
einer ist 19 ja sag ich doch die sind
ungefähr gleich alt und
wollte ich wollte ewig gerne mal mit dir
über etwas reden was völlig aus der mode
gekommen ist als begriff ja die jugend
von heute wenn mein sohn mich hopsten
will sagt der papa da ist sie wieder die
böse jugend von heute
den jungen von heute ist ein schöner
begriff will eigentlich nicht mal im
ernst benutzt oder das kriegten wir doch
zu hören ja genau die jugend von heute
total verkommen und so genau ja aber
heute sagt man ja nicht dass die jugend
irgendwie vorkommen wäre oder als ich
ich denke mal so die alten nazis im
dritten reich sozialisiert worden die
dann auf die jugend von heute geschimpft
haben die meinen ja irgendwie die jugend
hätte keine sitte und keinen anstand ja
ja genau und den vorwurf macht ja der
heutigen generation eigentlich keiner
das stimmt wobei der vorwurf von denen
damals die das geäußert haben und leute
die im ist einmal in der zeit auch ihre
karrieren gemacht haben also das ist
natürlich auch steigen um anne passow
wenn man sich mal anschaut was sie
angerichtet haben dass die sich dann
getraut haben der jugend von heute
vorwürfe machen sagt mein vater immer
alles andere ist 33 wäre der trug dann
in den 50er jahren ja ein bisschen
länger ein bisschen länger also nicht so
wie ich sondern einfach ein bisschen
länger und musste sich dann von der
generation von der nazi generation quasi
der täter generation erklären lassen was
sitte und anstand ist ja also leute die
hurra geschrien hatten im dritten reich
fanden also dass etwas zu lange haare am
kragen sitte und anstand verletzt
also das war wirklich medizinische
situation und finde ich auch finde ich
auch aber ich glaube da hat auch
mittlerweile viel nachdenken eingesetzt
wollte trotzdem richard mal ganz
ernsthaft mit dir über die jugend von
heute sprechen ja ich
lass mich mal so sagen wenn man die wahl
hat ja teil einer großen gruppe zu sein
oder war teil einer ganz kleinen gruppe
zu sein würde man doch immer sagen lasst
uns lieber teil der kleinen gruppe sei
ja nur weil weniger konkurrenz am
arbeitsmarkt weniger konkurrenz um die
coolen jobs weniger konkurrenz um die
kohlen wohnungen weniger konkurrenz um
letzten endes dem platz im flugzeug das
heißt eigentlich denkt man doch
sozusagen teil einer kleinen gruppe zu
sein verspricht der sozusagen in der
business class durchs leben zu reisen ja
während wir die die die bösen boomer ja
das hat mittlerweile das antwort
geworden während wir sozusagen economy
class reisen weil wir einfach so
wahnsinnig viele sind und diesen harten
konkurrenzkampf gibt aber ich glaube
dass das nicht so ist und wenn man sich
an fängt man damit zu beschäftigen
also dieses vermeintliche verwöhnt seien
der jugend von heute die vermeintlichen
privilegien die sollen einfach mal da
anfangen mit dem viel und wenig seien ja
also die baby boomer generation klar wir
waren immer zu viel es gab keine
lehrstellen man kriegt keinen
studienplatz fall so viele bewerber auf
irgendetwas waren und so der spiegel hat
mal vor knapp 20 jahren mit
titelgeschichte gemacht die hieß
generation geh du das sind wir ja mit
einer damals nach guido westerwelle ich
hab's fährt der sollte für damalige
verhältnisse jungen ja
quasi politisch karriere gemacht hat das
hat sich ja heute auch verschoben da
kann mir noch kristina schröder und wäre
noch alles hier jünger war und da gab es
noch diese kohls mädchen
es gab ja noch so es gab ja noch so eine
andere familienministerin oder sowas ja
aber der ist ja gerade ich heim komme
ich aber gleich auf den namen die ba mit
720 ministerin
warte ich habe sie vor augen er ich auch
so ungefähr so ähnlich aus wie angela
merkel heraus sagen 'wow genau exakt die
brille
da kommen wir gleich also jedenfalls
generation guido bedeutete die die immer
zu viel sind
und
das merkt man aber nicht weil wir ja
nichts anderes kennt man denkt ja das
ist normal genau es ist normal dass es
keine studienplätze gibt es gibt noch
normal dass es dass man sich sorgen
macht ob man arbeitsplatz kriegt weil
überleg mal die zeit ende der 70er
anfang der 80er jahre war die
arbeitslosigkeit hoch und so man hält ja
immer den zustand in dem man reinkommen
für normal und
eine sache haben wir für normal gehalten
ein privileg dass unsere kinder nicht
mehr haben wo auch immer man zufällig
hinkam waren überall massen von kindern
mit die anderen fahren da kann ja aber
das war auch gut weil man hatte auch
immer kinder zum spielen und musste sich
eigentlich gar nicht verabreden dass es
gab unglaublich viele kinder in meiner
kindheit ja die irgendwo auf dem hof rom
lungerten und keine pläne für den tag
hatten und solche kinder also wenn ihr
jetzt vorstellt so
hinter dem ruf allah in solingen geht
einmal einem schönen sommertag durch und
guck mal wie viele kinder da rumlungern
ohne pläne für den tag das gar nicht
mehr übrigens mir fällt gerade ein
claudia erneut das ist ihr auf die bin
ich gekommen eigentlich
könnte ich mal gucken was macht
eigentlich claudia nolte
gut ja bei so einer serie ist es waren
überall rauch worden dass kinder daran
dass also auf der einen seite kann man
sozusagen mehr wettkampf aber auf der
anderen seite es konnte auch viel mehr
quasi passieren dass man begegnete auch
unabsichtlich ganz vielen kindern bis
heute habe ich das gefühl in der
jüngeren generation ist die wenige
freizeit haben ja unheimlich viel schule
machen weil die wenige freizeit
eigentlich immer organisierte freizeit
genau und das finde ich ist ein ganz
ganz wichtiger unterschied weil ich
glaube dass ist prägend fürs leben und
ja das glaube ich auch aber lasst uns
darüber auch gleich sprechen richtig ich
wollte noch mal sozusagen mal nicht im
ganzen ein bisschen soziologisch nähern
weil ich das wahnsinnig interessant
findet man denkt immer soziologie ist
eigentlich so eine wissenschaft mit der
man nicht viel am hut hat aber das ist
in dem fall unglaublich interessant also
wenn man sich diese baby boomer
generation war so vorstellen ja ich habe
solche vergleich gelesen muss man sich
vorstellen im grunde wien peter wind
hütern der der gerade so ein wildschwein
verschluckt und verdaut ja so haben die
sich sozusagen das war vergleich in der
gesellschaft so einfach so durch
gearbeitet und alles mitgenommen was
ging ja wenn man sich mal mit klar
machen was das eigentlich bedeutet also
teil einer riesigen gruppe zu sein so
wie wir dann hat man erst mal echte
marktmacht viele viele konsumenten wir
treiben märkte wir haben geld das wir
ausgeben usw und das ist der grund warum
peter maffay immer noch auf tournee ist
ja das ist das ist der grund warum der
mini noch gebaut wird das ist der grund
warum all diese dinge nach wieder und
auch konzert ist ausverkauft sagt ja wir
sind eine echte markt power und das
andere und ich wir haben eine gewisse
chance im durchschnitt ziemlich alt zu
werden so also unglaublich länger als
jede generation zuvor mit markt power
ausgestattet auf dem markt auch zu sein
so und und genau was auch übrigens dazu
führt ich habe eine studie aus england
gelesen ist es extrem interessant die
1956 geborenen in england ziehen im
schnitt
250.000 mehr und aus den sozialen
systeme also rente und alles was da los
ist als alle anderen als sie eingezahlt
haben medizin 250.000 pfund mehr aus den
sozialen systemen als sie eingezahlt
haben das ist so viel wie keine andere
generell so pro nase pro nase wie keine
andere generation vor ihnen der ihn
selbstverständlich auch keine generation
nachwehen wichtig weil das system
geändert werden muss weil das system
ändert werden muss ganz genau das kann
nur genau eine generation macht das
system kaputt genau
hast du wenn du dir die vuma also wie
rede ist von uns ja die bösen buben
hatte ja immer ihr bösen bouma und er
hat auch recht wir haben wahlpanne wir
haben eine unfassbare macht an der urne
gegen uns kann kein politiker politik
machen keiner absolut keiner wenn du
wenn du dir auch david die zahlen
anguckt auf jeden boomer kommen
hunderttausende gleichen alters die
einfach wählen gehen auf jeden
millennials kommen so viel weniger leute
gleichen alters die wählen gehen das
heißt wir haben marktmacht und wir haben
richtige politische macht das heißt der
ganze staat die sozialleistungen die
förderprogramme die ganze politik ist
wenn du mal genau hinguckt ausgerichtet
auf uns auf puma das heißt dieser
vermeintliche vorteil die jüngeren leute
sind wenige und deswegen sozusagen das
vermeintlich coole reisen durchs leben
in der business class stellt sich bei
genauerer betrachtung raus es ist
eigentlich eine reise in der holzklasse
es ist nicht business class tja das ist
eine reise in der holzklasse deswegen
weil auf der einen seite gibt es ja
etwas was wir haben was wir so
flächendeckend nicht hatten also so viel
liebe und aufmerksamkeit wie im
durchschnitt ein heute 19-jähriger
20-jähriger gekriegt im durchschnitt
ausnahmen bestätigen die regel dass es
klar aber im durchschnitt gekriegt hat
liebe vom vater ist noch in unserer
generation groß system hat die
abwesenden vätern ja die hat
leistungsansprüche stellten aber die er
nicht allzu viel liebe auszuteilen
hatten gar nicht zu reden von der
generation davor das heißt also sie
haben die diesbezüglich komfortabelste
kindheit in der geschichte der
menschheit emotionalen emotional ja auch
materiell also im durchschnitt natürlich
wiederum wohlhabender aufgewachsen als
jede generation zuvor
auf der anderen seite kippen wir die
bösen buben die größten probleme der
menschheit einige quasi gut lösbar
vor vor die füße also wir wir verlassen
doch die welt irgendwann mit dem bösen
lächeln eines zauberers dabei ist das
eine unlösbare aufgabe hinterlässt
etwas dran ist was dran aber du gerade
sagt ist es interessant die wachstum
wohlstand auf aber auch da nur ist total
spannend mal genau hin zu gucken was ist
das für ein wohlstand die wahrheit ist
es ist unser wohlstand ja es ist der
wohlstand denn den sozusagen wir boomer
erarbeitet haben die möglichkeit auch
dazu hatte man sich mal anschaut wie der
wohlstand gewachsen ist ich sag mal auf
vielen ebenen de wir sind die generation
die noch in der lage war eine wohnung
und ein haus zu kaufen wir haben aber
diese preise getrieben auf eine art und
weise dass ein junger mensch heutzutage
es fast unmöglich in ballungsräumen eine
wohnung oder ein haus zu kaufen ja das
muss man genauer beschreiben also in der
generation unserer unsere eltern begann
eigentlich das flächendeckende sich
häuser leisten können auch nicht für
jeden ja aber führt sie über die risiken
jetzt sehr allgemein natürlich muss man
vielleicht in der generalisierten davor
in der generation davor hatten die
wenigsten ein eigenes haus also die die
generation meiner eltern ist die
generation eigenheim reihen eigenheim ja
wo überall in den städten die das
bisschen wasser noch an bauern wiese war
verkauft wurde ja und überall mehr oder
weniger graue siedlung entstanden für
eigenheime ich selbst bin ab dem elften
lebensjahr auch in den reihen eigenheim
eckhaus groß geworden und in der
generation in der wir sind da kamen dann
quasi der häufige anspruch nicht einfach
nur ein reihenhaus irgendwo sondern das
stadthaus am richtigen ort
oder die eigentumswohnung am prenzlauer
berg das sind so quasi insignien unserer
generation
natürlich muss mal wieder dazu sagen hat
nicht jeder gehabt hat auch nicht jeder
mit seinem eigenen geld bezahlt wenn ich
jetzt sage eigentumswohnungen am
prenzlauer berg natürlich auch die
wohlstands generation unserer eltern ihr
geld angelegt
aber dennoch ist es so was du gesagt
hast man es ist die zeit der der der
explodierenden mieten es ist die aktie
der explodierenden eigentums kosten und
und und das stimmt also da wurde einem
markt extrem verengt in der zeit nicht
verhängt das ist unsere power das ist
die marktmacht wie wir treiben sozusagen
die märkte weil wir einfach schlicht und
ergreifen so viele sind ja das ist
interessant und wenn du dir die beweist
wir haben ein paar mal darüber
gesprochen und ich doch manchmal der
sendung darüber einer der gründe die
dazu geführt haben dass leute wie donald
trump am ende er im amt waren und einer
der gründe warum wir so viele
verwerfungen sehen und das gefühl haben
das ganze system wird so instabil ist ja
dass dieses aufstiegsversprechen nicht
mehr funktioniert und wenn man mal
genauer hinguckt so zur demografische
daten dann siehst du dass die
millennials sind die erste generation
die wirklich deutlich erkennbar weniger
verdient haben als generationen davor in
dem sinne von davor gab es dieses lange
lange aufstiegsversprechen es gab dieses
gefühl du hängst dich richtig rein und
zusätzlichen werden und dann besonders
du dich auch mal
weißt du durch wasser ersetzt wird sagt
durch die lotterie des werbens exakt
diese generation hat natürlich auch mehr
als jede generation zuvor je geerbten
sabrina aber eben nicht jeder ja und
dann haben wir dieses große problem dass
das erben der größte turbo ist um die
schere zwischen arm und reich
auseinander gehen zu lassen das ist
richtig die die aufsteller aufstieg ist
weniger einfach als er früher gewesen
ist die soziale durchlässigkeit hat
enorm nachgelassen ja und gleichzeitig
verschärft sich die ungleichheit durch
serben genau das ist der soziale
sprengstoff für das einundzwanzigste
jahrhundert was auch interessant ist das
war mir auch so nicht klar wenn man wenn
man da mal genauer hinschaut
da gibt es ein interessantes
paradoxon sondern interessanten
widerspruch wenn du heute mit mit jungen
leuten spricht dann kannst du ja
passieren dass jemand sagt du ich komm
grad zurück von meinem sozialen jahr auf
den malediven
[Gelächter]
aktiven erreicht das erste mal
vielleicht mit mitte vierzig oder so und
ja
ich sag's als beispiel
die die sind überall auf der welt
unterwegs
nötig weil reisen ist günstig kinder
auch als günstig aber gleichzeitig ist
sozusagen die mobilität dieser junge
leute gibt sehr interessante
untersuchungen dazu die ist nicht so
groß wie wir denken dies sogar
eingeschränkter als zum beispiel die
mobilität von dir und mir
einer der gründe ist in
innenstädten wo es wirklich diesen
harten kampf um günstige wohnungen usw
gibt können die sich wohnungen nicht
mehr leisten das führt dazu dass die in
der nähe von mama und papa bleiben die
wichtigste lebensversicherung junger
leute ist eine bank namens mama und papa
ja dass das erste hotel und an einer
bank
das ist übrigens interessant was du
sagst weil ich erinnere mich es gab so
große gesellschaftliche diskussionen so
etwa vor zehn jahren da hatte ein
amerikanischer autor buch geschrieben
das wurde dann hunderttausend mal wo die
begriffe übernutzt benutzt von den
sunways und den anywhere erinnerst du
dich daran ja klar der wahl gesagt also
wer reich ist unser oberschicht oder zur
oberen mittelschicht gehört er ist ein
juwel der hat eine wunderbare ausbildung
der hat kann zahlreiche sparen der
studiert im ausland und er kann überall
in der welt arbeiten und tut das auch
genau ist also zum beispiel nicht mehr
darauf angewiesen in deutschland zu
bleiben mag deutschland doch den bach
runtergehen und dem gegen die nanny us
gegenüber sind die sabres ja das sind
diejenigen die sich das nicht aussuchen
können ja die arbeiten in der baumschule
ja oder die arbeit auf dem bau und so
weiter und die können jetzt nicht sagen
doch ich gehe mal jetzt dahin und dahin
und dahin das heißt also die freiheit
ist auf die für die anywhere die quasi
unsichere kantonisten sind
vaterlandslose gesellen auf der einen
seite und die sabres auf der anderen das
ist die frustrierte klasse aus der er
sich dann donald trump speist exakt und
es gibt ein wichtiges korrektiv was man
dazu machen muss das ist eine falsche
vorstellung vom leben der andy us
es ist sehr interessant dass mir das mal
ein topmanager erklärt hat er gesagt
wird das stimmt nicht er hat mich mal
gesagt ich sollte mal darauf gucken bei
banken zum beispiel die wie viele leute
in den führungsetagen deutscher banken
sind keine deutschen
wie viele in den führungsetagen
amerikanischer banken sind keine
deutschen ja oder schweizer banken und
du wirst sehen überall ist die
überwältigende mehrheit sind dann
deutschen schweizer oder amerikaner
das heißt also wenn es nachher die
spitzenposition geht ist das nicht zu
globalisiert wie wir glauben das heißt
du musst die die leute bleiben quasi auf
ihrem heimatmarkt sie kehren mindestens
nach einiger zeit wieder auf den
heimatmarkt zurück weil ihre
karrierechancen auf dem heimatmarkt
besser sind als im ausland
synthes und ja also das geht sicherlich
nicht für programmierer na das ist ein
komplett globalisierter markt aber es
gilt vielen wirtschaftsbereichen
also wir haben nicht besonders viele
ausländische konzern chefs von dax
unternehmen
ist wahrscheinlich so
wird noch mal gerne zu diesen zu diesem
punkt richard diese vermeintliche
mobilität alles geht das ist ja das
gefühl dass wir den jungen leuten noch
gerne so zum vorwurf machen ihr wisst ja
gar nicht wir hatten ja gar keine
möglichkeiten aber ihr heute ihr und ihr
könnt aus dem vollen schöpfen und ihr
könnt einfach das stimmt nicht auch der
lebensraum ist total interessant der
lebensraum junger leute heute in städten
ist deutlich kleiner als noch vor ein
paar jahrzehnten wir leben auf sehr viel
mehr fläche als junge leute heute tun
wegen der teuren breiter genau
das ist das ist das ist eine sache die
er jedes jahr das der berühmte
unterschied zwischen den potentiellen
möglichkeiten und den realen möglich
sagt also für die ganze generation
gesprochen gilt das natürlich mit den
potentiellen möglichkeiten
ein schönes beispiel ist wo kann man
heute alles studieren wo konnte ich
studieren ich bin ich lieg franzose aus
ja in die nächst sinnvolle
universitätsstadt also ich hatte die
wahl zwischen wuppertal düsseldorf und
köln ja aber da war köln am spannendsten
und ist ein hartes schicksal ja als ich
auf die idee zu kommen zu sagen auch ich
würde eigentlich gerne in berlin
studieren oder ich erkenne in london
studieren wird von hätte ich den leben
sollen also das war eigentlich und
denken es war möglich aber auch oder
werden drei- oder viermal noch
inzwischen durch im während des studiums
ins ausland gehen und irgendwelche
merkwürdigen zertifikate und abschlüsse
um dann nachher mit so einem stapel von
papieren zurückzukommen die wichtigste
einstellungsvoraussetzung dann später
sind also dass kamen in meiner welt
nicht vor das gab es zwar ganz
vereinzelt vielleicht in meinem alter
war wirklich selten also ich weiß dass
das wenn man journalistik studiert hatte
dann konnte man irgendwie ein semester
eine französische uni gehen und dann
konnte man wenn man später ein buch
geschrieben hat dann reinschreiben
studierte in köln und paris
was immer man in diesem halben jahr
gemacht so konnte er so ein bisschen
aufblasen damit aber heute ist ja fast
schon reguläre erwartung in vielen
studiengängen dass man das macht genau
und das setzt ja voraus dass man das
will ich meine es gibt auch und auch in
der jungen generation viele
bodenständige menschen die gar nicht das
interesse daran haben sich einen
globalisierten lebenslauf zuzulegen
denen das eigentlich gar nicht
entspricht und die das jetzt nicht als
freiheit empfinden sondern bin ja es
werden sollen keine feier ist als druck
genau exakt was das ist der punkt war
dominiert diese freiheit auch nutzen und
eine freiheit die ich nutzen muss ist
keine ja ich finde ja weil du das gerade
so sagt kommt mir nicht der gedanke der
der zum beispiel für mein leben so
wichtig immer war und das ist etwas was
die eben nicht mehr haben aufgrund von
ökonomischen zwängen
und aufgrund der tatsache dass das leben
dann vielfach sich so darstellt wie es
ist so unfassbar teuer du bist
eigentlich gezwungen im hotel mama papa
zu bleiben und dann heißt eine hausbank
auch mama und papa du hast die
möglichkeit überall auf der welt zu
studieren wenn deine eltern dazu in der
lage sind du hast die möglichkeit die er
vielleicht eine wohnung irgendwo in der
innenstadt zu kaufen wenn deine eltern
der massiv unter die arme greifen
richtigen da kann man sagen ja das ist
ja noch wunderbar was beschwert ihr euch
eigentlich aber es gibt einen ganz
entscheidenden punkt bei der geschichte
ich fand immer mein leben dann am besten
und deswegen ist das etwas was für mich
zentral ist in meinem ganzen leben
selbstbestimmtheit
unabhängig zu sein will ich mit 20 mit
25 mit 30 die ganze zeit immer noch zu
papa oder zu mamer laufen und sagen du
passt auf ich bräuchte man euro haßmann
dollar das will man doch nicht sondern
will doch selber in der lage sein
schaffen was der punkt und die chance
hatten wir glaube ich mehr als dies
heute hier ob wir wollten oder nicht das
richtig fit ich geb dir von der sache
recht andererseits muss man sagen ich
glaube dass das viel häufiger ist dass
man so ein enges verhältnis zu seinen
eltern hat auch wenn man mitte 20 ist
als das früher war
also ich meine ich sieht was ja wie
viele leute fahren mit ihren eltern im
urlaub und sind schon 23 oder 25 das
wäre für mich die hölle gewesen
also das war genau das alter wo ich das
am wenigsten gemacht hat wann warst du
das erste mal im urlaub richard
das erste mal allein im urlaub also
jetzt noch über abgesehen also
jugendgruppen und sohn ich war nämlich
die verkehr termin schweden aber allein
dass ich erst mal allein im urlaub war
ich mit 20 während meines zivildienstes
da war ich vier wochen in griechenland
ist das ist die szene mit der wer bin
ich beginne ja ja genau da fängt quasi
die eingangsszene von wer bin ich und
wenn ja wie viele die spieler die da
liegt am strand in am strand in kryta
naxos was genau
am strand von ostia anna in naxos
der zum damaligen zeitpunkt so quasi die
partie ich halt bewohnt war und von dem
ich mir habe sagen lassen ich habe mir
gar nicht erst die bilder angeguckt dass
da jetzt nur teure ferienressorts sind
ist das also die läuft dieser strand der
mal allen gehört wo wir am strand
gewohnt um geschlafen haben ohne zelt
sogar also nur so hin unter decken
der ist heute privatisiert übrigens auch
weißt du wer in diesen wohnungen sitzt
da sitzen auch wieder böse bodmer drin
in ihren wohnungen in naxos sitzen böse
bube ja
ja und ja für stimme die chemie nicht zu
entdecken übrig gelassen haben wir beim
letzten mal drüber gesprochen wenn du
sagst mir hat es die freiheit ihr stand
quasi die welt offen war das ja auch
verbunden mit dem gefühl du kannst noch
in spannenden platz für dich in der welt
finden und ich glaube in einer welt in
der alles so vorgefertigt und so zu und
so voll ist wo wir alles verstopft haben
ja wo wir überall jede küste wo wir
häuser gestellt habe wo wir schon schon
schon schon alles kolonialistisch in
beschlag genommen haben ja geistig
seelisch materiell da ist für die junge
generation glaub ich viel viel
schwieriger den eigenen weg zu finden
eigenen weg zu gehen
ja und wenn sie das war doch schon wenn
die kinder sich mit 7 5 was interessiert
haben dann kommen die eltern und haben
die gleiche überfordert der atx gab
sofort ein angebot noch etwas unfertig
ließe wenn ich das ehrlich das ist
einmalig schöne in die blockflöte
reingepasst wird ja und schon
begabtenförderung im
blockflötenunterricht und so also da
kann ich ja nichts zu entdecken wo immer
meine idee war ja keine tausend
antworten ist man sofort die lust wieder
verloren glaubt nie hat man die
blockflöte damals aus denselben gründen
weggenommen haben solltest kein
häufigkeit und katja w ich war dermaßen
unbegabt im bereich blockflöte dafür war
ich extrem begabten wie tasten ja ich
habe mich immer magischen jetzt auch
später komplett du weißt haben schon
darüber gesprochen komponieren ist ein
sehr großes wort ja für das was ich
damals gemacht habe lasst uns sagen ich
habe ich habe klänge zusammenmontiert
irgendwann aber ehrlich gesagt ich ja
das ist übrigens das einzige dinge zum
thema selbstbestimmung und dass ich
irgendwie bereue ich denke mal man da
hätte ich noch ein bisschen mehr die
richtung gehen sollen ein bisschen mehr
musik machen sollen ich habe neulich so
eine produktion gehört ich höre immer so
darauf die musik produziert ist von
kennst du die pfalz driver nein das ist
das ist ein 1 1 dj und das klang sehr
cool gemacht irgendwie dachte wow das
ist irgendwie da hat eine echt ahnung ja
von von logic audio usw sind so die
programme mit denen das mit dem man das
macht und dachte wer ist dieser typ das
klang so international das klang sowie
amerika weißt du irgendwo kalifornien in
ein cooles hippies studio habe ich den
verortet stellte sich raus dieser job
als treiber wir hatten ein
wikipedia-eintrag und wird in wahrheit
auf den namen slobodan petrovic und lebt
ausschließlich holz steine in der nähe
von hamburg wenn man mit dem namen so
lebt ja genau aber ein echt guter
musiker der irgendwie viel so
zusammenschraubt irgendwer dachte ich
augen man slobodan petrovic muss ich
immer war besuchen ich glaube dass wir
immer großen spaß machen aber wir kommen
vom thema ab ich bin nur sagen also
diese geschichte diese diese
vermeintliche sozusagen dieses verwöhnt
seien dieses diese diese dieser dieses
dieses zuviel an möglichkeiten ja diese
diese endlose wahl von von 30 oder von
beruflichen perspektiven das ist in
wahrheit wenn du mal genauer hinguckt
ist das gar nicht so großartig und
interessanterweise hat das einen
positiven nebeneffekt
würde man auch nicht vermuten wenn du
heute jemanden fragt und sagst wie es
eigentlich um familie bestellt dann
würden alle sagen ah familie
das spielt nicht mehr die rolle diesmal
gespielt hat das stimmt nicht familie
ist heute wichtiger denn je weil wir
immer dafür gesorgt haben dass die nach
uns uns brauchen wir haben die auf eine
art abhängig gemacht ja das stimmt das
stimmt also erst mal haben wir nicht
viel dafür getan sie frühzeitig
selbstständig zu machen dadurch dass wir
uns immer um alles gekümmert haben also
die die flächendeckende helikopter rey
hat ja quasi der seelischen emanzipation
keinen vorschub geleistet sondern hat ja
die kinder häufig und jugendlichen zu
einer gewissen unmündigkeit erzogen so
dass dieses reifen ja wer aus west
fliegen selber eine wohnung mieten und
daran denken seine stromrechnung zu
bezahlen
ja so sein handy selber bezahlen sich um
tausend dinge kümmern ja sehen dass die
abfalltonne ausgeräumt wird in der lage
sein mit seinen eigenen händen etwas zu
renovieren und so also diese fähigkeiten
waren denke ich in unsere generation
noch etwas ausgeprägter als sie jetzt
also die hilflosigkeit hat sich hat
zugenommen dazu weiß man ja auch
bekanntermaßen dass die motorik
abgenommen hat ja das ist jetzt
natürlich noch mal richtig aus er ist
einfach da gibt es unglaublich viele
studien so was also wäre mir nicht
gelaufen und auch wer mit einem wisch
bewegung aufregt ja also alles quasi
über sein smartphone erledigt der breg
bestimmte
körperliche fähigkeiten nicht mehr im
gleichen maße aus also die anzahl der
der jungs die heute zwei linke hände ab
ja die ist sicher viel größer als früher
dafür können sie andere dinge ja absolut
können sie erstaunlich lange möglich
natürlich
also ich finde ich finde sie haben wir
durchschnitt eine komplexere
auffassungsgabe weil sie in komplexere
welten rein
wohnen sind genau dann dann haben sie
ein anderes ich habe ein schwieriges
wort kontingents bewusstsein also früher
habe in unserer welt war die dinge
einfach war schwarz-weiß wir waren ja
schon politischen rechts links
eingeteilt und das war's dann quasi ja
heute ist's doch die welt so komplex und
so kompliziert und je mehr ich darüber
weiß
und so mehr weiß ich auch was ich nicht
weiß oder so und ich glaube da sind sie
viel weiter als wir waren also bei mir
war das jedenfalls so dass ich noch mit
18 oder 19 gedacht habe was die großen
antworten anbelangt bin ich da ziemlich
nah dran
und heute mit 750 würde ich sagen ich
bin ein ziemlich weit von weg aber ich
befürchte dass die heutigen 18 19
jährigen dieses selbstvertrauen das sie
das schon richtig machen dass ich auf
dem richtigen weg sind dass sie wie das
früher hieß den durchblick haben ich
glaube dieses gefühl hat kaum noch einer
ja und ich habe auch das gefühl das ist
ein riesen frust gibt weil die sich von
uns her unverstanden fühlen ich habe
nämlich das gefühl weil du sagst
komplexe dinge und systeme ich meine die
verdienen faktisch weniger auch
inflationsbereinigt die leben in
kleineren wohnungen sie haben weniger
geld faktisch für privaten konsum sie
haben weniger marktmacht und politisch
werden sie auch nicht wirklich gesehen
und das kannst du ja auch ich meine wenn
man sich dass man anschaut und die die
wahlprogramme der letzten jahre das ist
doch das ist doch von von von vorne bis
hinten sozusagen der blick auf genau uns
und die generation davor zugucken wie
können wir bei denen uns möglichst
ein freundliches image schaffen die
alten den wohlstand erhalten naja es ist
das credo jeder verträgt ja weil weil du
legst dich mit dieser riesigen gruppe
legst du dich nicht an weil wenn du das
tust dann bist du morgen weg und das ich
weiß gar nicht ich habe das lange
unterschätzt ich glaube dass das
politikern heute extrem bewusst ist weil
so wird politik gemacht ja und
gleichzeitig wissen wir genau so kann
man politik nicht weitermachen exakt
weil eben diese boomer generation
ich war da gibt es also erschreckender
statistiken also man kann ja sagen so
die letzten beiden generationen
die haben mehr co2 in die luft geblasen
als seit den zeiten des neandertalers
bis zum zweiten meines urgroßvaters
ja also was wir zerstört haben auf
dieser welt das ist beispiellos ja und
übrigens immer noch und immer noch
nahezu ungebremst und mit dem verweis
auf wohlstand mit dem verweis auf für
uns natürlich also ich kenne nur
politiker reden wo es immer darum geht
als angela merkels lieblingswort neben
gemeinsam war in jeder
regierungserklärung wachstum
und es ist auch das ist so der der der
ungeschriebene verfassungsauftrag dessen
was jeder bundeskanzler bundeskanzlerin
deutschland zu leisten hat ja wachstum
sicherstellen
und das hat natürlich dazu geführt dass
du auf der einen seite unserer
öko-bewusstsein gestiegen ist langsam
aber sicher über viele stufen hinweg
aber auf der anderen seite wir eben in
dieser wachstumsfeld leben und uns aus
dieser matrix auch bis heute nicht
ernsthaft befreien können weil wir keine
alternativen
es gibt es gibt auch dazu eine total
interessante zahl die es einem auch so
nicht klar weil du gerade sagtest wir
also wir die die buber und die vor uns
wir haben so viel co2 in die luft
gebracht wie niemand vor uns wir alle
zusammen wir alles vorher nicht sagt er
wir alle zusammen vorher nicht exakt ja
wenn du dir mal anschaust also wenn man
es mal zurückreichen jetzt sozusagen es
geht sagen wir es gibt dieses ziel dass
wir immer noch versuchen zu erreichen
und von dem er bei ernst zu nehmende
leute sagen das wird wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr funktionieren das berühmte
1,5 grad
wird es wirklich ernst meinten und wenn
wir wirklich ernsthaft die absicht
hätten dieses 1,5 grad ziel zu erreichen
dann würde das und es ist total
interessant dann würde das mit blick auf
die generation nach uns auf die
millennials generation set usw würde das
bedeuten die dürften nur noch ein achtel
des co2 ausstoßen das wir ausgestoßen
habe ein achtel überlegt was da stellt
sich die frage wie soll das gehen und
genau und dann sind wir wieder in der
alten diskussionen sind also die daran
glauben dass es möglich ist na ja das
sind nicht viele
die setzen entweder darauf dass es
technisch möglich ist dass der
technische lösung für alles finden wo
wir so viel co2 ausstoßen
zum beispiel dass man keine tiere mehr
ist sondern stattdessen die bürger
künstlich herstellt in zellkultur
deutlich bessere co2 bilanz dass man
irgendwann mal autos mit wasserstoff hat
deutlich bessere co2 bilanz also wenn
das irgendwann gelingt den grünen
wasserstoff in solchen mengen zu
produzieren also das ist so diese eine
idee das läuft über technik und die
andere idee es ist kann nur über
radikalen verzicht laufen und die
wahrheit ist weder über das eine kleine
darüber dass andere allein wird das
laufen war der radikale verzicht stürzt
sturz die gesamte gesellschaft ins chaos
richtig da ist gesicht ich überhaupt gar
keine schrittweise transformation hin
und sich darauf zu verlassen dass jedes
problem technisch gelöst wird ist
insofern als dass die technik zwar immer
hilft aktuelle probleme zu lösen aber
auch immer wieder neue probleme
geschaffen hat
also das auto hat er geholfen das
mobilitätsproblem zu lösen was auch zu
einer riesen wirtschafts explosion
geführt hat aber auf der anderen seite
eben die ökologischen folgen schäden
angerichtet und so ist das immer mit
technik technik verlagert probleme
gelöst sie sehr selten endgültig
dass mein thema ist auch das sozusagen
das psychologische dahinter ich meine
was bedeutet das team psychologisch
welcher generation konflikt kommt denn
darf uns zu wenn wir die wir co2 die
luft gejagt haben als gäb's kein morgen
wenn wir jetzt den generationen nach uns
erklären müssen dass das jetzt
gefälligst mal ab sofort anders läuft
das heißt hier verzichtet bitte und wir
machen weiter wie gehabt wir müssen wir
das gar nicht erklären gebe ich glaube
die wissen dass ich das anders genau und
die wissen dass ich auch nicht auf den
boden du bist das ja auch nicht von uns
ich habe immer während der korona
debatte gedacht da war es doch immer
wichtig zu sagen die jungen müssen auf
die alten rücksicht nehmen war immer
ganz wichtige argumentation sind sie
haben ja auch gemacht und sie haben es
sehr sehr weitgehend gemacht wir haben
die kinder mit masken in die schule
geschickt und so weiter also die
generation unserer söhne hat com partys
feiern können ja alles mögliche wurde
abgesagt und somit teil ihrer jugend
verloren durch die korona maßnahmen
umgekehrt ist es doch im hinblick auf
das klima ist immer noch die gleiche
forderung stellen dass jetzt die älteren
rücksicht auf die jungen die hier noch
gerne 70 jahre leben wollen müssen
ich höre diese forderung nicht die die
hörst zunächst auch interessant ich
meine corona oft zitiert der satz ich
meine wir haben eine impfpflicht für 17
jährige verlangt oder 17 jährige dazu
aufgefordert ganz dringend sich endlich
impfen zu lassen um 70 jährige
impfwillige zu schützen das war die
absurde situation und es ist ja
eigentlich bis heute ja und wenn wir das
jetzt wenn wir das jetzt umdrehen ja
dann müssten eigentlich die 17-jährigen
uns dazu auffordern unseren lebensstil
zu ändern damit sie noch eine zukunft
haben ja so sieht's aus
dazu ich weiß nicht mehr wo ich das habe
man sehr interessanten vergleich es gibt
doch immer diese befürchtung von eltern
die am wochenende wegfahren und dann
zurückkommen und hinter zwischenzeit
haben die kinder diese fürchterliche
party gefeiert und die bude komplett
zerlegt the structure partys
aber eigentlich ist auch dieses bild in
wahrheit schräg eigentlich sind wir in
eine komplett zerstörte bude
hinterlassen gelang es macht macht mal
was draus richtig in die lte auf dem
motto hier habt ihr jetzt eine gute
schule besucht ihr habt das jetzt alles
gelernt ihr wisst genau wo die probleme
sind und jetzt löst man die probleme die
wir angerichtet hat ja das ist
tatsächlich so
deswegen verbietet sich im grunde
geschrumpft jede kritik an der jüngeren
generation wie wir das alles aufbürden
wir sind wir eigentlich also wir haben
ab die am anfang gesagt wer waren die
leute eigentlich die meinem vater gesagt
haben das verstößt gegen sitte und
anstand lange haare zu tragen und
genauso kann man fragen wer sind wir
eigentlich wäre dieser generation z
vorschriften machen zu wollen wie man
richtig leben oder ihnen zu sagen was
sie alles nicht können ja wo wir die
größten herausforderungen der menschheit
nicht bewerkstelligt haben die frage ist
ja die nach der lösung also wenn du wenn
man sich das mal so zur demografisch so
anschaut also
diese vermögenskonzentration
und nochmal wir reden jetzt sehr
pauschal und es gibt natürlich
wir hassen keine alten leute wir sind ja
selber bald alte leute davon wir mögen
alte leute ich habe großen respekt vor
der lebensleistung der allermeisten
menschen und natürlich ist mir völlig
bewusst dass es viele arme alte auch
gibt um die man sich kümmern muss aber
wenn man sich einfach nur die die ganz
pauschal die zahlen anschaut dann muss
man sagen da gibt es eine gigantische
vermögenskonzentration in der in den
händen der boomer die wir sind die jetzt
anfangen in rente zu gehen
und mit steigender lebenserwartung
bedeutet das dass immer weniger junge
dieser gigantischen zahl von menschen
ein auskömmliches dasein bescheren
müssen wie soll das gehen ich weiß ja
dass ich wenn ich damit schon
beschäftigt habe und dass ich ja der
aller festesten einer felsenfesten
überzeugung dass unsere umlagesystem das
ja darauf beruht dass die jeweils
späteren generationen die
vorangegangenen generationen finanzieren
durch ihre arbeit dass dieses system
nicht mehr zeitgemäß obwohl ich dieses
system für eine große lange
erfolgsgeschichte halte und denke das
war mal die über 50 60 jahren verdammt
gutes system ja aber man sollte hier
keinen toten gaul durchs ziel reiten
sondern wirklich erkennen dass da nichts
zu retten ist und dass man an diesen
patienten nicht eine schönheitsoperation
nach der anderen jetzt durchführen
sollte der hat krebs er hat er
wirtschaftlich überleben und das ist
glaube ich eine sehr wichtige
verpflichtung die wir eingehen können
also das könnte unsere die boomer
generation noch leisten ein für die
jüngere generation
gerechteres und besser funktionieren das
rentensystem zu schaffen ich glaube das
ist unglaublich wichtig also wir können
ihnen nicht auch noch unser kaputtes
rentensystem vor die füße kippen weil
das bedeutet
das ja schon jetzt quasi fast wir die
situation haben dass drei junge leute
die arbeiten ein rentner finanzieren und
der tag ist in sichtweite wo zwei junge
leute einen rentner finanzieren und
irgendwann einer ein rentner finanziert
also ich meine wir können doch nicht
warten bis die in der politisch
verantwortlichen positionen sind also in
20 25 jahren um das zu ändern sondern
das sollten wir ihnen noch mitgeben und
so die fahrt das verantwortungsgefühl
sollten wir haben ihnen das nicht
aufzuhören
das interessante ist ja ich habe das
gefühl auch das und wissen ganz genau
die beschäftigen sich damit viel
intensiver als wir ist immer der als zu
jung warst mit 20 erst wieder über rente
nachgedacht ich nicht
ehrlich gesagt bis heute nicht naja ein
bisschen hatte man die am hinterkopf
hatten also wild und gefährlich lebt
dass man diesen zustand in ihrem leben
erreicht
habe kennst ja den den berühmten satz
von russland als nicht der am meisten
gelebt hat der im ältesten geworden ist
sondern derjenige der meisten gefühlt
hat ja gefühl wichtiges stichwort dieses
dieses lebensgefühl vielleicht lass uns
darüber zum schluss muss man satz
verlieren richard dieses lebensgefühl
dieser jüngeren generationen hat neulich
interessanten satz von thomas gottschalk
zum spielen gelesen thomas gottschalk ja
zitat die junge generation heute ist so
weich gekocht und so ängstlich auf
erfolg bedacht
ja das ist da ist sicher was dran aber
sie sind in dem ja auch das produkt
ihrer erziehung oder also haben ihre
eltern sie nicht weich gekocht und waren
ihre eltern nicht ängstlich darauf
bedacht dass ihre kinder mal erfolgreich
werden
also ich glaube das spiegelt die er die
eltern generation wieder so viel ich
finde ich auch wir haben das ist auch
schon
so ein vorwurf der da drin ist sagt
alles solche weicheier ich ja
ausgerechnet jemand der so
berufsjugendliche ist wie thomas
gottschalk und der sich sicherlich so
wie pippi langstrumpf als kind gesagt
hat er nie erwachsen werden dass
ausgerechnet der so europa spruch lässt
ist auch erstaunt
ja vorliegen also die die die frage ob
die wirklich weich gekocht sind ich
würde das elegante und frage stellen
naja ich gekocht sind sie schon weil sie
von vielen härten des lebens abgerungen
wissen auch wir wieder sagen denn
natürlich wiederum nicht alle es gibt
kinder die impfraten milieus
aufgewachsen ist wenn der zahn
aufgewachsen bist bis nicht weichgespült
aber wir reden sozusagen über die
mehrheit
und da glaube ich ist das einem
weichgespült was dran aber es haben ja
nicht selber gemacht na also die sind
doch durch die ganzen schon bestehende
vorher durch gemangelt und durch
geschleudert worden wie haben sie sich
ja nicht freiwillig ausgesucht nicht die
gleichen die gleichen jugendlichen
während die in den slums von manila groß
geworden wären nicht weichgespült es ist
ja keine frage ihres charakters ja genau
und und er ehrlich gesagt ist das auch
so ein bild mit dem wir häufig
konfrontiert waren ein indianer kennt
keinen schmerz und man muss die härten
des lebens kennenlernen usw ich hab halt
das gefühl und deswegen frage ich da
danach ich habe das gefühl dass die
herausforderung heute eine völlig andere
ist und das haben wir noch gar nicht
wirklich verstanden ich lies dir mal an
einen kurzen text vor von ronja menzel
ja die sich junge autoren die sich
darüber gedanken gemacht hat schreibt
folgendes heute haben wir allen
freiheiten der welt türen stehen uns
offen möchte ich lieber architekt werden
möchte ich mit ärzte ohne grenzen durch
afrika reisen möchte ich meinen ersten
1000 damit immobilien machen möchte ich
mit dem laptops unterwegs sein und geld
verdienen sicherheit prestige was ist
wichtig und jetzt kommt schon als kinder
bekamen wir gesagt dass wir werden
können was immer wir wollen unterstützt
von eltern und nachhilfelehrern waren
wir auf guten schulen schafften manchmal
mehr schlecht als recht gute abschlüsse
so dass uns heute die türen der
selbstverwirklichung offen stehen
gleichzeitig aber gleichzeitig aber
schrumpft die möglichkeit der
planbarkeit dadurch dass uns alles offen
steht fällt es uns schwer uns
festzulegen dadurch dass wir uns ständig
entscheiden müssen haben wir angst etwas
zu verpassen
die möglichkeiten werden zu last
entscheidungen treffen so qual
selbstverwirklichung zur pflicht ist ein
extrem guter text finde ich
absolut also ich hab schon schon früher
viel geschrieben über die multifunktions
gesellschaft die eben auch eine
bedrohung ist und ich habe in meinem
buch über letztes buch also freiheit für
alle geschrieben in einer
arbeitsgesellschaft keine arbeit zu
haben ist eventuell immer noch besser
als in einer sinn gesellschaft keinen
sinn zu finden und das besagt natürlich
genau das gleiche aus je größer die
auswahl umso schwieriger kannst du dich
entscheiden richtig das ist eine sehr
gut dokumentierte erkenntnis der
sozialpsychologie also wenn du wenn du
dir was neues kauft und du hast die wahl
aus drei oder fünf verschiedenen
gegenständen ja ob das jetzt schmucker
autos oder was auch immer mode dann hast
du meistens nach einer das gefüge was
ich genau richtig entschieden wenn du
aber die auswahl aus 100 dingen hast
hast du immer das gefühl haben du hast
ich frage entschieden und ich kenne da
hast du den unterschied zwischen unserer
generation und der generation heute
definitiv weil es ist ja es ist ja
dieses gefühl es geht ja nicht darum
dass man irgendwie was verpasst sondern
es geht darum dieses ständig diese
schlechte gewissen zu haben dieses
gefühl ich muss doch jetzt mal zu potte
kommen und ich muss sehr schnell wissen
wo es immer im leben lang geht also
diese unbeschwertheit diese leichtigkeit
die ist weg hab ich das gefühl ja und ja
auch die erwartungshaltung der eltern
früher war die erwartungshaltung vieler
eltern ja du muss sehen dass irgendwo
sicher unterstützung wie gameforge ist
ja dass das dass du deinen
lebensunterhalt bestreiten kannst heute
ist die erwartung der eltern dass du
dein ding findest dass du deine zum teil
sehr gut versteckte hochbegabung aus
lebst
dass du irgendwas was einen schon wissen
lassen was andere nicht machen
ja ja ja das sind das sind
herausforderungen die sind doch sehr
sehr viel größer als früher mein gott
wie schlicht war früher die
erwartungshaltung natürlich auch ein
bisschen banal und so hört ja aber erst
heute also ich meine leute wollen doch
die die eltern dass diese ganzen
ungeschliffenen rohdiamanten irgendwann
anfangen zu funkeln dass der punkt also
und dann und dann bei dir selber also
als junger mensch die erkenntnis mist
ich bin doch kein genie wie sage ich es
meinem vater richtig richtig ja das ist
eine gute beschreibung der männer ja
also wir wer so über überfordert und
manchmal auch überschätzt worden ist ja
das ist ja das schrecklichste was hier
passiert ist ja viel besser man wird
unterschätzt ja absolut sagen generation
deutlich häufiger waren ja aus dir wird
nie was und so es gibt es ja heute
selten dass eltern über ihre kinder
denken aus den wird nix wenn die in der
schule verhältnis auffällig sind dann
denkt man eben ja aber die sind
wahrscheinlich besonders kreativ oder so
die werden mit ganz tollen job im
silicon valley kriegen weil diese
unangepasst sind und so also die die
fantasien der eltern im hinblick auf die
generalität ihrer kinder sind uferlos
und das ist auch eine hypothek die viele
kinder mit sich rumschleppen müssen ja
ich weiß oli schulte hat dazu mal dass
ein stadtauto der mittlerweile aber die
seiten gewechselt hat er ist jetzt als
sprecher für die für die grünen tätig
juli schuld in großartiger auto aber mal
bei uns zu gast und der hat damals als
es den den ärger um an der liga baerbock
und ihre biografie gab hat er so
sinngemäß muss das auf dem kopf zieht
und marieke geschrieben
annalena baerbock ist sozusagen typisch
für diese generation ist glaube ich 40 0
für diese generation deren bloße ankunft
auf der welt schon gefeiert wird
und dann gehen die weiter und wenn sie
das erste mal geradeaus über die straße
laufen können wird das auch schon
gefeiert weil es absolut großartig ist
und es wird so lange betrieben von den
eltern und von den um sie herum dass sie
irgendwann und das entscheidende satz
irgendwann ihre eigene mittelmäßigkeit
für genial halten ich glaube dass es das
heute in der tat häufig gibt gibt ja
genau und früher war es sogar so dass
das leute gab die vielleicht nicht
unbedingt genial aber sehr begabt haben
um das begabung waren die ein leben lang
nicht erkannt worden also in unserer
generation geht das ja noch da aber je
weiter du zurückgehen absolut ja wie
viele begabte musiker gab es gegeben ja
die aber auf dem bau arbeiten mussten
und absolut also als das leben doch
überhaupt gar kein wunschkonzert war und
jetzt gibt es quasi ins genau anderen
gekehrt genau das stimmt wirklich in
meinem einer kind hat das total
interessant was du da sagst ich habe
ganz oft auf den bauernhöfen zum
beispiel auch in meiner familie und so
weiter da hat man ganz oft leute
getroffen dass dieses diese klage habe
ich absolut im ohr von leuten die sagten
ja der oder die die hatten eigentlich
echt potenzial für was wirklich großes
aber das war nicht möglich studieren
gehen bessere schulen besuchen war nicht
möglich und am ende ist koch geworden
oder ist eine köchin geworden oder hat
sich als knecht irgendwie
durchgeschlagen was auch immer aber
schadewaldt da war immer ein großes
talent das haben wir alle immer gemerkt
also diese diese klage und diese wehmut
und diese melancholie die kenne ich
absolut aus meiner jugend ist das ist
also heute heute noch in allen
entwicklungsländern von ganzen staaten
der dritten welt und was weiß ich was ja
da fragt dich wenn du in somalia
irgendwo großfürst kein mensch nach
deinem begabung
da wird auch deine geburt nicht im
vergleichbaren sinne als sensation
gefeiert weniger goutiert auch nicht die
ganze zeit gesagt wir außergewöhnlich
und großartig du bist
also interessant richard war ein
interessanter austausch als im grunde
sozusagen ein thema von zwei seiten die
man sich da so nährt also ich glaube
schon dass wir
als er hat die die bösen worbis nochmals
zu zitieren ich glaube wir müssen da
echt mal unsere perspektive verehrt habe
eins muss man natürlich hat eben auch
nur wir können aber nichts dafür dass
zuma sind genauso wie eine generation z
nichts dafür kann dieser generation
anzug über das recht und eigentlich
gehört ja zur individualität dazu dass
man sich nie für identische hält mit der
generation in der man lebt ja
also man hält sich ja immer für doch
irgendwie ein bisschen anders als die
anderen
und dann muss man dann im alter
zurückblicken und dann erkennen dass sie
das von dem was man gemacht hat das ist
was sie anderen in ähnlicher weise eben
auch genauso gemacht haben aber während
andere drin steckt wenn man jung ist und
so weiterhin es uns gar nicht so war es
war das ist wahr also lasst uns zum
schluss sagen uns jetzt auch absolution
zu erteilen wir haben wirklich unser
bestes gegeben mehr war halt nicht drin
wir haben es nicht besser gewusst
wir haben es besser gewusst aber wir
haben es nicht besser gekonnt
besser gemacht genau richard ich danke
dir sehr das nicht war sehr inspirierend
auch bald
[Musik]
eine produktion von mpeg 2 und posters
bei ohren er im auftrag des zdf
[Musik]